양자 정보와 계산 이해하기 강의에 다시 오신 걸 환영해요. 저는 John Watrous이고 IBM
Quantum의 교육 기술 책임자예요. 이번 강의는 시리즈의 15번째이고, 양자 오류
수정을 다루는 4번째 단원의 세 번째 강의예요. 지금까지 9 qubit Shore
코드, 7 qubit Steane 코드, 5 qubit 코드 등 몇 가지 양자 오류 수정 코드 예시를 살펴봤고, 이를
수학적 기반으로 설명하고 분석할 수 있게 해주는 안정자 형식도 다뤘어요. 이 외에도 많은 양자 오류 수정
코드를 설명하고 분석할 수 있어요. 방금 말씀드린 코드들은 분명히 흥미롭고 양자 오류 수정 탐구를
시작하기에 자연스러운 출발점이에요. 문제는 이 코드들이 아주 낮은 오류율만 허용할 수 있다는 거예요.
5개, 7개, 9개 중 1개의 qubit 오류를 수정하는 건 나쁘지 않지만, 우리가 추측하는 것처럼
대규모 양자 컴퓨팅을 실현하려면 그보다 훨씬 많은 오류를 허용할 수 있어야 할 거예요.
이번 강의에서는 좀 더 정교한 양자 오류 수정 코드 구성들을 처음으로 살펴볼 거예요. 지금까지 본 것들보다
훨씬 높은 오류율을 허용할 수 있고, 실제 양자 오류 수정의 유망한 후보로 여겨지는 코드들이에요.
실제 물리적 장치에서도요. 강의의 간략한 개요를 소개할게요. CSS 코드라는
양자 오류 수정 코드 클래스부터 시작할 거예요. 이 코드는 이를 처음 발견한 연구자들인 Robert Calderbank, Peter
Shor, Andrew Steane의 이름을 따서 지어졌어요. CSS 코드 구성을 통해 특정 고전
오류 수정 코드 쌍을 결합해 양자 오류 수정 코드를 만들 수 있어요. 그 과정에서
고전 선형 코드를 간단히 살펴보고, CSS 코드의 기본 속성들도 이야기할 거예요.
강의의 두 번째 파트는 토릭 코드라고 알려진 코드에 관한 거예요. 이건 근본적이고 정말
아름다운 양자 오류 수정 코드 예시로, 상대적으로 높은 오류율을 허용할 수 있어요. 실제로
토릭 코드는 단일 양자 오류 수정 코드 예시가 아니라 코드의 무한한 패밀리예요. 각각
2부터 시작하는 양의 정수에 대한 코드가 있어요. 강의의 마지막 파트에서는 다른 몇 가지
양자 코드 패밀리에 대해 간략히 이야기할 거예요. 토릭 코드와 밀접하게 연결된 surface 코드와
color 코드도 포함해서요. 사람들은 1940년대부터 고전 오류 수정 코드를 연구해왔어요.
이건 매력적이고 풍부한 주제예요. 선형 코드는 아마도 가장 단순한 유형의 고전 오류
수정 코드예요. 이 맥락에서 선형이라는 단어가 정확히 무엇을 의미하는지 잠깐 후에 설명할게요. 간단히
표현하면 이들은 고전적인 안정자 코드예요. 곧 CSS 코드가 기본적으로 고전 선형 코드 쌍을
결합해 양자 오류 수정 코드를 만드는 것임을 알게 될 거예요. 그 논의를 위해 고전
선형 코드에 대한 몇 가지 기본적인 것들을 이해해야 해요. 먼저 이 전체
논의에서 Σ를 이진 알파벳으로 사용할 거예요. 이제 고전 선형 코드라고 할 때, 길이 n의 이진 문자열 집합 C를 의미해요. 어떤
양의 정수 n에 대해서요. 단 하나의 기본 속성만 만족하면 돼요. u와 v가 C에 속하는 이진 문자열이면 문자열
u XOR v도 C에 속해야 한다는 거예요. 여기서 u XOR v는 u와 v의 비트별 배타적 OR을 의미해요.
이건 시리즈의 양자 알고리즘 파트인 5번째와 6번째 강의에서 여러 번 봤던 거예요. 이것이 고전
코드가 선형이라는 의미예요. 본질적으로 길이 n의 이진 문자열을 n차원 벡터로 생각하는 거예요.
각 항목은 0 또는 1이지만, 실수나 복소수 위의 일반적인 벡터 덧셈 대신
모듈로 2 덧셈을 사용해요. 이게 바로 XOR이에요. 그러니까
두 코드워드 u와 v, 즉 C에 속하는 이진 문자열이 있으면, u + v 모듈로 2, 다시 말해 u XOR
v도 코드워드여야 해요. 그리고 이 함의는 u가 v와 같더라도 참이어야 해요. 그 가능성을 배제할 수 없어요.
그리고 이는 모든 고전 선형 코드에는 반드시 전부 0인 문자열이 포함되어야 함을 의미해요. 왜냐하면
어떤 문자열과 그 자신의 비트별 XOR은 전부 0인 문자열이기 때문이에요. 예를 들어, 3비트
반복 코드는 고전 선형 코드예요. 특히 u에 대한 선택지가 두 가지, v에 대한 선택지가 두 가지 있어요.
가능한 쌍들을 살펴보면, 비트별 XOR을 취할 때 항상 코드워드가 나온다는 걸 쉽게 알 수 있어요.
또 다른 예시는 [7,4,3] 해밍 코드예요. 이건 가장 먼저 발견된 고전 오류
수정 코드 중 하나예요. 길이 7의 이진 문자열 16개로 구성돼요. 이 문자열들의 선택에는 아주 단순한 논리가 있지만
이 영상에서는 설명하지 않을 거예요. 이 문자열들이 뒤집혀 있는 경우도 있지만
지금은 중요한 점이, 이 문자열들 중 어느 두 개를 골라 XOR하면 코드 내의 다른 문자열을 얻는다는 거예요.
그러니까 선형 코드예요. [7,4,3]이라는 표기에서 단일 대괄호는 이전 강의에서 안정자 코드에 대해
말했던 이중 대괄호 표기와 유사한 의미예요. 하지만 여기서는 고전 선형
코드에 대한 거예요. 특히 코드워드는 7비트이고, 코드워드가 16개이므로 코드를 사용해 4비트를 인코딩할 수 있어요.
거리 3 코드이기도 해요. 즉, 한 코드워드에서 다른 코드워드를 얻으려면 최소 3비트를 뒤집어야 해요.
그리고 이는 최대 1비트 오류를 수정할 수 있음을 의미해요. 이것들은 단순한 예시들이에요.
[7,4,3] 해밍 코드 예시조차도 코드워드를 단순히 나열할 때는 다소 신비로워 보여요. 그러니 고전 선형 코드를
더 잘 설명할 방법이 필요해요. 자연스러운 방법이 두 가지 있어요. 하나는 고전
선형 코드를 코드를 생성하는 최소 코드워드 집합으로 설명하는 거예요. 이 코드워드들의 모든 가능한
부분집합을 XOR하면 전체 코드를 얻을 수 있어요. 이건 화면에 수학적 표현으로 나타나 있어요.
또 다른 방식으로는, 이 코드를 벡터 공간의 부분 공간으로 보는 거예요. 이 생성자 집합은
그 부분 공간의 기저예요. 산술이 모듈로 2로 이루어지는 벡터 공간임을 기억하세요. 생성자가 M개 있으면,
코드는 2의 M제곱개 원소를 갖게 돼요. 각 생성자는 코드의 원소 수를 두 배로 늘려요.
이진 알파벳 위의 고전 선형 코드는 항상 2의 거듭제곱 수의 문자열을 포함한다는 사실과
일치해요. 고전 선형 코드를 설명하는 두 번째 자연스러운 방법은 패리티 체크예요. 이는 코드의 문자열과 같은 길이를 가진 이진 문자열의
최소 목록인데, 코드의 문자열은 정확히 이 패리티 체크 문자열들 각각과의 이진 내적이 0인 것들이에요.
이진 내적은 단순히 일반적인
내적인데, 각 항목의 곱의 합을 모듈로 2로 계산하는 거예요.
내적을 모듈로 2로 계산하는 거예요. 이것도 5번째 강의에서 쿼리
알고리즘 맥락에서 다뤘던 거예요. 이를 패리티 체크 문자열이라고 부르는 이유는, 주어진 문자열 u가 v와 이진 내적이
0인 경우, v의 1에 해당하는 u의 비트들이 짝수 패리티를 가지는 경우에만 그렇기 때문이에요.
고전 선형 코드를 패리티 체크 문자열의 최소 목록으로 이런 방식으로 설명할 때, 각 패리티
체크 문자열은 코드의 문자열 수를 반으로 나눠요. 그래서 이 두 가지 방식으로 설명되는 단일 코드에서는 항상 m + r = n이 성립해요.
여기서 중요하게 알아둘 점은, 이진 내적이 형식적 의미에서의 내적이 아니라는 거예요. 특히
두 문자열의 이진 내적이 0이라고 해서, 우리가 일반적으로 생각하는 방식으로 직교한다는 의미가 아니에요.
예를 들어, 문자열 1,1과 그 자신의 이진 내적은 0이에요. 그러므로 이 패리티 체크 문자열 중
하나가 코드 자체에 속하는 것도 가능해요. 이건 그냥 기억해 두세요.
예를 들어, 이미 알고 있듯이 3비트 반복 코드는 선형 코드예요. 그래서 이 두 가지 방식 모두로
설명할 수 있어요. 특히 작동하는 생성자 선택이 하나뿐인데, 그게 111이에요. 또는 이 두 패리티 체크 문자열로
코드를 설명할 수도 있는데, 이전 논의에서 친숙해 보일 거예요.
[7,4,3] 해밍 코드의 경우 이 생성자들과 이 패리티
체크들을 사용할 수 있어요. 그리고 여기서 모든 패리티 체크 문자열이 코드 자체에 속하는 것으로 나타나요.
고전 선형 코드에 대해 마지막으로 안정자 형식과 연결하는 한 가지 언급을 하자면, 이 패리티 체크
문자열은 Z와 항등 파울리 행렬만 있는 안정자 생성자와 동일해요. 예를 들어 3비트 반복 코드의 패리티 체크
문자열 110과 011은 안정자 생성자 ZZ⊗I와
I⊗ZZ에 정확히 대응해요. 이건 이전 강의에서 이런 종류의 관측값에 대한 우리의 논의와 일치해요.
다음은 CSS 코드를 다룰 거예요. 이건 같은 수의 비트를 인코딩하는 특정 고전 선형 코드 쌍을
결합해서 얻을 수 있는 안정자 코드예요. 어떤 두 고전 선형 코드에도 적용되는 건 아니에요.
곧 보겠지만, 두 코드 사이에는 특정 관계가 있어야 해요. 하지만 이
구성은 양자 오류 수정 코드에 대한 많은 가능성을 열어줘요. 부분적으로는 75년 이상의 고전
코딩 이론에서 배운 것들을 바탕으로요. 안정자 형식에서 Z와 항등 파울리 행렬만 포함하는 안정자
생성자는 패리티 체크와 동일하다고 이미 언급했어요. 예를 들어, 3비트
반복 코드에서 패리티 체크 문자열 110과 011을 사용할 수 있어요. 이는 코드의 모든 문자열에서 왼쪽 두 비트가
같고 오른쪽 두 비트가 같음을 강제해요. 이 두 패리티 체크 문자열은 안정자
생성자 ZZ⊗I와 I⊗ZZ에 정확히 대응해요. [7,4,3] 해밍 코드의 경우 이
패리티 체크 문자열들을 사용할 수 있고, 각 1을 Z로, 각 0을 항등으로 교체하면 이 안정자 생성자들에 대응해요.
이 안정자 생성자들이 익숙해 보일 수도 있는데, 7 qubit Steane 코드의 여섯 안정자 생성자 중 세 개이기 때문이에요.
이건 분명히 우연이 아니고, 여기서 무슨 일이 일어나는지 곧 정확히 볼 거예요. 이런 안정자 생성자를 Z
안정자 생성자라고 이름 붙일 거예요. 즉, 파울리 Z와 항등 텐서
인수만 있는 거예요. X와 Y는 Z 안정자 생성자에 절대 나오지 않아요. 또한 X와 항등 파울리 행렬만
나타나는 안정자 생성자도 고려할 수 있어요. 이런 안정자 생성자는 Z 안정자 생성자와 완전히 유사하게 생각할 수 있어요.
차이는 기본적으로 표준 기저가 아닌 플러스-마이너스 기저에서 패리티 체크를 설명한다는 거예요.
예를 들어, [7,4,3] 해밍 코드로 돌아가서, 7 qubit Steane 코드의
나머지 세 안정자 생성자를 생각할 수 있어요. 이들은 이 코드의 Z 안정자 생성자와 정확히 같은 패턴을 따르는데,
이번에는 Z 대신 X를 사용해요. 이 세 안정자 생성자만으로 얻는 것은
여기에 표시된 16개 상태를 포함하는 코드예요. [7,4,3] 해밍 코드의 문자열에 대응하는 표준
기저 상태에 Hadamard gate를 적용하면 얻을 수 있어요. 물론 코드 공간에는
이 상태들의 선형 결합도 포함돼요. 자연스럽게, 이런 형태의 안정자 생성자를 X 안정자 생성자라고 해요.
이번에는 Y나 Z가 허용되지 않아요. 이제 간단한 표현으로 CSS 코드를 정의할 수 있어요.
CSS 코드는 Z 안정자 생성자와 X 안정자 생성자만으로 표현할 수 있는 안정자 코드예요.
즉, Y는 허용되지 않고, X와 Z가 같은 안정자 생성자에 나타나는 것도 안 돼요.
이게 명확한지 확인하기 위해, 안정자 생성자를 선택하는 방식에 자유가 있다는 걸 기억해야 해요. 이 정의가 말하는 건
CSS 코드는 Z와 X 안정자 생성자만 선택하는 것이 가능한 코드라는 거예요.
하지만 원한다면 Z나 X 안정자 생성자가 아닌 다른 안정자 생성자를 선택할 수도 있어요.
Z 안정자 생성자와 X 안정자 생성자가 모두 있는 CSS 코드의 가장 단순한 비자명 예시가 여기 있어요.
유효한 안정자 코드라는 것은 이전 강의에서 이미 알고 있으므로, 눈으로 보는 것만으로도 확인할 수 있어요.
코드 공간은 1차원이에요. Bell 상태 |Φ+⟩로 span되는 공간이에요. 두 안정자 생성자가 이 벡터에
자명하게 작용한다는 걸 화면에 표시된 ebit의 두 표현과
01 및 플러스-마이너스 기저에서의 패리티 체크로서의 안정자 생성자 해석을 통해 볼 수 있어요.
7 qubit Steane 코드도 CSS 코드의 또 다른 예시예요. 이 생성자 선택으로는
Z와 X 안정자 생성자만 있고, 이미 유효한 안정자 코드라는 걸 알아요.
9 qubit Shor 코드도 또 다른 예시예요. 이번에는 여섯 개의 Z 안정자 생성자와
두 개의 X 안정자 생성자만 있어요. 두 유형 사이에 균형이나 대칭이 있을 필요가 없어요.
하지만 실제로 유효한 안정자 코드여야 한다는 건 매우 중요해요. 그 의미는
각 Z 안정자 생성자가 각 X 안정자 생성자와 교환 가능해야 한다는 거예요. 그러니까
두 유형의 생성자를 독립적으로 선택할 수는 없어요. 이 부분에 대해서는 강의 후반부에 조금 더 이야기할게요. 다음으로 CSS 코드의 오류
감지와 수정을 다룰 거예요. 9 qubit Shor 코드에서 관찰했던 속성인,
X 오류와 Z 오류를 독립적으로 감지하고 수정할 수 있다는 것이 CSS 코드 일반에 성립해요.
이를 더 설명하기 위해, 7 qubit Steane 코드 같은 CSS 코드를 고려해 볼게요. 다른 CSS 코드여도 되지만요.
기본 아이디어는 Z 안정자 생성자가 X 오류를 감지하지만
Z 오류에는 완전히 무감각하다는 거예요. Z 안정자 생성자는 항상 Z 오류와 교환 가능하기 때문이에요.
또한 Z 안정자 생성자는 Z 오류에 대한 수정으로 적용하는 Z gate와도 교환 가능해요.
유사하게, X 안정자 생성자는 Z 오류를 감지하지만 X 오류와 수정에는 완전히
무감각해요. 따라서 Z 안정자 생성자는 비트 플립, 즉 X 오류로부터 보호하는
고전 선형 코드를 나타낸다고 생각할 수 있어요. X 안정자 생성자는
플러스-마이너스 기저에서 완전히 독립적으로 플러스와 마이너스 상태 사이의 플립으로부터 보호하는 고전 선형 코드를 나타내요.
즉, 위상 플립 오류나 Z 오류로부터요. 이제 Steane 코드에서 무슨 일이 일어나는지 상당히 명확해요.
단순히 비트 플립 오류를 위한 [7,4,3] 해밍 코드와 위상 플립 오류를 위한 [7,4,3] 해밍 코드예요.
Z 안정자 생성자와 X 안정자 생성자가 교환 가능해야 한다는 사실은 다시 한번 필수적이에요.
그렇지 않으면 유효한 안정자 코드가 아닐 거예요. [7,4,3] 해밍 코드가 이렇게 작동하는 건 행운이라고 할 수 있지만,
이런 방식으로 결합하면 유효한 안정자 코드를 줄 수 있는 고전 선형 코드 쌍에는 많은 다른 선택지가 있어요.
이제 CSS 코드 일반으로 돌아가서, Z 안정자 생성자가 최대 j개의 X 오류를 수정하고, X 안정자 생성자가 최대
k개의 Z 오류를 수정할 수 있다고 해봐요. Steane 코드의 경우 j와 k는 모두 1이에요.
[7,4,3] 해밍 코드가 하나의 비트 플립을 수정할 수 있으니까요. 하지만 일반적으로 이 숫자 j와 k는 다를 수 있어요.
그러면 오류의 이산화에 의해, CSS 코드는 j와 k의 최솟값만큼의 qubit에서 발생하는 임의의 오류를 수정할 수 있어요.
신드롬을 측정할 때 일부 qubit에서의 임의의 오류는
효과적으로 확률적으로 X 오류, Z 오류 또는 둘 다의 조합으로 붕괴되기 때문이에요. 그런 다음
X 오류와 Z 오류는 독립적으로 감지하고 수정할 수 있어요. 따라서 교환 가능한 X와 Z 안정자 생성자를 주는 방식으로
서로 잘 맞는 두 고전 선형 코드가 있다면, 이들을 결합해서 얻는
CSS 코드는 기본적으로 방금 설명한 의미에서 두 코드의 오류 수정 속성을 상속해요.
하지만 치러야 할 대가가 있다는 점에 주목하세요. 두 고전 코드로 비트를 인코딩하는 것만큼 많은 qubit를 인코딩할 수 없어요.
CSS 코드의 총 안정자 생성자 수는 두 고전 코드의 패리티 체크 수의 합이기 때문이에요.
그리고 각 안정자 생성자는 코드 공간의 차원을 절반으로 줄여요.
예를 들어, [7,4,3] 해밍 코드는 세 개의 패리티 체크만 있으므로 네 개의 고전 비트를 인코딩할 수 있어요.
반면 7 qubit Steane 코드는 여섯 개의 안정자 생성자가 있어서 하나의 qubit만 인코딩해요.
이번 강의에서 CSS 코드 일반에 대해 마지막으로 설명할 것은 CSS 코드의 코드 공간과
그 모습에 관한 거예요. 또한 두 고전 선형 코드가 CSS 코드를 형성하기 위해 결합될 수 있는 호환 관계를
좀 더 자세히 살펴볼 기회도 될 거예요.
N qubit에 대한 임의의 CSS 코드를 고려하고, Z1부터 Zs까지를 Z 안정자 생성자에 대응하는 n비트
패리티 체크 문자열이라고 해봐요. 이는 Z 안정자 생성자로 설명되는 고전
선형 코드, 이걸 CZ라고 부를게요. Z 안정자 생성자에 대응하는 코드임을 기억하기 쉽게요.
이 코드는 화면에 표시된 형태예요. 즉, 코드는 각 패리티 체크 문자열과의 이진 내적이 0인 모든
문자열 u를 포함해요. 만약 원한다면, 이 같은 문자열에서 파생된 다른 코드도 고려할 수 있어요.
이걸 DZ라고 부를 거예요. 여기서의 아이디어는 문자열 Z1부터 Zs를 패리티 체크 문자열이 아닌
생성자로 생각하는 거예요.
지금 이 코드를 왜 생각하고 싶은지는 명확하지 않지만, 가능하고 이 논의와 관련이 있을 거예요.
이 코드는 CZ의 쌍대 코드라고 하며, 흔히 CZ⊥, 즉 위첨자로 수직 기호가 있는 CZ로 표기해요.
하지만 여기서는 DZ라고 부를게요. D가 쌍대(dual)의 약자라 기억하기 쉬울 거예요.
X 안정자 생성자로도 비슷한 걸 할 수 있어요. 이번에는 CX가 X 안정자 생성자에 대응하는 패리티 체크 문자열을 가진 고전 선형 코드이고,
DX는 이 코드의 쌍대 코드예요. 여담으로, CZ와 CX가
CSS 코드로 결합할 수 있는 호환성을 위해 성립해야 하는 조건을 이제 설명할 수 있어요.
이 코드들 자체로 표현하면, 구체적으로 DZ가 CX에 포함되거나
동등하게 DX가 CZ에 포함되어야 해요. 이제 이 두 코드에서 파생된 CSS 코드의 코드 공간을
설명하는 게 가능해요. 한 가지 방법은, 화면에 표시된 형태를 가지는 모든 벡터로 span되는 공간이라는 거예요.
말로 표현하면, 이들은 X 안정자 생성자에 대응하는 코드의 쌍대 코드 DX에 있는 문자열 위의 균일 중첩처럼 보여요.
이 문자열들은 Z 안정자 생성자에 대응하는 코드 CZ의 문자열로 이동되거나 XOR되어 있어요.
Steane 코드의 특정 경우에서 이게 어떻게 보이는지 곧 알게 될 거예요.
이건 말이 돼요. 코드 공간의 상태는 모든 안정자 생성자의 +1 고유 벡터여야 하는데, 특히 X 안정자 생성자 중 하나를 곱하는 건
대응하는 X 문자열로 XOR하는 것과 동일해요. 그래서 서로 다른 문자열로 이동된 DX 위의 균일 중첩이
이렇게 나타나는 거예요. 이 표현에서 문자열 y로 나타내는 이동의 서로 다른 선택은
같은 벡터를 줄 수도 있어요. 따라서 이 상태들이 모두 다른 건 아니지만, 전체적으로 코드 공간 전체를 span해요.
X와 Z 안정자 생성자와 그에 대응하는 코드 사이에 대칭이 있어요.
그 대칭을 사용해 X와 Z를 교환하는 방식으로 코드 공간의 벡터를 유사하게 설명할 수 있지만,
표준 기저와 플러스-마이너스 기저도 교환해야 해요. 그래서 이 표현에 Hadamard 연산이 나타나는 거예요.
이제 약속했던 예시인 Steane 코드를 보면, 0과 1 표준 기저 상태의 인코딩 가능한 두 가지 인코딩을 얻게 돼요.
특히, 0 상태는 [7,4,3] 해밍 코드의 쌍대 코드에 있는 여덟 개 문자열 위의 균일 중첩으로 인코딩할 수 있어요.
이 쌍대 코드는 [7,4,3] 해밍 코드의 문자열 절반으로 나타나요. 1 상태도 유사하게 인코딩할 수 있는데,
이 경우 모든 문자열이 전부 1인 문자열로 XOR되는 점만 달라요.
이 쌍대 코드는 [7,4,3] 해밍 코드의 절반의 문자열로 이루어진다는 게 나타나고, 1 상태도 유사하게 인코딩할 수 있는데 모든 문자열이 전부 1인 문자열로 XOR되는 거예요.
이 경우에요.
그 문자열이 [7,4,3] 해밍 코드에는 있지만 그 쌍대 코드에는 없기 때문이에요. 마지막으로 하나 덧붙이자면, 코드 공간의 벡터들이 어떻게 생겼는지는
사실 그다지 신경 쓰지 않아도 돼요. 코드를 사용하기 위해 이걸 알 필요가 일반적으로 없으니까요.
그래서 이 설명이 명확하지 않더라도, 너무 걱정할 필요는 없어요. 하지만 CSS 코드의 코드 공간에 있는 벡터들이
어떻게 생겼는지 묻는 건 당연히 자연스러운 질문이고, 이 설명이 그 답을 제공해요.
다음으로 토릭 코드라고 알려진 특정 CSS 코드를 다룰 거예요. 이건 위상적 양자 오류 수정 코드로 알려진 것의 예시예요.
이 코드는 1997년에 Alexei Kitaev가 발견했어요.
실제로 토릭 코드는 단일 코드가 아니라, 최소 2 이상의 양의 정수 각각에 대한 코드 패밀리예요.
이 코드들은 몇 가지 핵심 속성을 갖고 있어요. 첫 번째 핵심 속성은
모든 안정자 생성자가 파울리 연산으로서 낮은 가중치를 가진다는 거예요. 특히 모두 가중치 4를 가질 거예요.
이건 좋은 거예요. 각 안정자 생성자 측정이 너무 많은 qubit를 포함할 필요가 없다는 뜻이니까요.
양자 LDPC 코드 또는 양자 저밀도 패리티 체크 코드라고 말하는 경우가 있는데,
이 용어가 의미하는 게 바로 이거예요. 여기서 낮다는 건 4를 의미해요. 그러니 토릭 코드는 양자 LDPC 코드의 예시예요.
토릭 코드는 또한 기하학적 국소성이라고 불리는 것도 가져요. 안정자 생성자가 낮은 가중치를 가질 뿐만 아니라,
qubit를 공간적으로 배치해서 각 안정자 생성자 측정이 서로 가까운 qubit들만 포함하도록 할 수 있어요.
이렇게 하면 원칙적으로 이러한 측정을 구현하기 더 쉬워요.
그리고 마지막으로, 이 코드들은 큰 거리를 가져서 상대적으로 높은 오류율을 허용할 수 있어요.
이 코드들이 어떻게 작동하는지 설명할게요. 먼저 L을 최소 2 이상의 양의 정수로 놓고,
소위 주기적 경계를 가진 L×L 격자를 고려해봐요.
예를 들어, L=8일 때의 L×L 격자가 여기 있어요. 오른쪽과 아래쪽의 선이 점선임을 주목하세요.
아이디어는 오른쪽의 점선을 왼쪽의 선과 같은 선으로 생각하고,
유사하게 아래쪽의 점선을 위쪽의 선과 같은 것으로 생각하는 거예요.
이런 구성을 실제로 물리적으로 구현하려면 3차원이 필요해요.
특히, 먼저 왼쪽과 오른쪽을 맞추어 원통을 만들고, 그런 다음 원통을
구부려서 끝의 원들, 즉 격자의 위아래 가장자리였던 것들이 만나게 하거나,
위아래를 먼저 맞추고 옆면을 맞출 수도 있어요. 양방향 모두 작동하고, 이 논의에서는 어떻게 해도 상관없어요.
우리가 얻는 건 토러스, 즉 도넛이에요. 타이어 내부 튜브로 생각하는 게 더 좋은 이미지일 수도 있어요.
이건 속이 꽉 찬 게 아니라, 격자가 실제로 토러스의 표면만 된 거거든요.
이게 토릭 코드라는 이름이 유래된 곳이에요. 격자의 인접한 점들 사이를 이동할 수 있다고 할 때, 이런 토러스 위에서 움직이는 방식은
화면의 위 가장자리를 벗어나면 아래에서 나타나고 마찬가지로 왼쪽과 오른쪽 가장자리에서도 그런 오래된 비디오
게임을 해봤던 사람들에게 익숙할 거예요.
이게 3차원 공간의 토러스에 대해 구체적으로 이야기하는 것과 대조적으로, 이 격자를 설명하는 방식이에요.
다음으로 qubit들이 격자의 모서리에 배치된다고 상상해봐요.
화면에 그림으로 나타나 있는데, qubit는 파란색 실선 원으로 표시돼요.
점선 위에 배치된 qubit들은 실선이 아닌 걸 주목하세요. 그건 이미 위쪽이나 왼쪽의 것들로 그 qubit들을 표현했기 때문이에요.
위쪽과 왼쪽의 선이 아래쪽과 오른쪽의 점선이 나타내는 선과 정확히 같다는 걸 기억하세요.
이 qubit들을 모두 세면 2×L² qubit가 나와요. 이를 보는 한 가지 방법은, 수평 모서리에서 L² qubit, 수직 모서리에서 L² qubit를 얻는다는 거예요.
그게 qubit들의 배치이고, 토릭 코드 자체를 설명하려면 안정자
생성자만 설명하면 돼요. 두 가지 유형이 있어요. 첫 번째는 Z 안정자 생성자예요.
이들은 그림의 타일 또는 면에 대응해요. 두 번째는 X 안정자
생성자예요. 이들은 그림의 꼭짓점에 대응해요. 예를 들어, 여기 안정자
생성자 하나가 있는데, 이 타일에 접하는 각 qubit에 대한 파울리 Z 연산 하나를 텐서 곱하고 나머지 모든
qubit에는 항등 행렬을 사용하는 거예요. 그러면 가중치 4 파울리 연산이 나와요. 그리고 X 안정자
생성자 예시가 있는데, 이 꼭짓점에 인접한 네 qubit에 파울리 X 행렬이 작용하고
나머지 모든 qubit에는 항등 행렬이 있어요. 마찬가지로 가중치 4 파울리 연산이에요.
두 유형의 안정자 생성자 모두에서, 주기적 경계에서 감싸는 것들도 포함하는 게 중요해요. 이걸 하는 X 안정자 생성자 예시가 여기 있어요.
유효한 안정자 코드를 얻으려면 안정자 생성자들이 교환 가능해야 해요. Z 안정자 생성자들끼리는 모두 교환 가능해요. Z는 자신과 교환 가능하고 항등은
모든 것과 교환 가능하기 때문이에요. X 안정자 생성자들도 마찬가지예요. Z 안정자 생성자와 X
안정자 생성자가 서로소인 qubit 집합에서 비자명하게 작용할 때도 교환 가능함이 명확해요. 여기 표시된 두 생성자처럼요.
나머지 가능성은 Z 안정자 생성자와 X 안정자 생성자가 겹치는 경우예요.
그럴 때는 항상 두 qubit에서 겹치므로 안정자 생성자들이 교환 가능해요. ZZ와 XX가 교환 가능하기 때문이에요.
이건 최소 안정자 생성자 집합이 아니에요. 특히 모든 Z 안정자 생성자를 곱하면 항등이 나와요. 각 qubit가 Z에 의해 두 번,
즉 그 qubit에 접하는 두 타일 각각에 대해 한 번씩 곱해지기 때문이에요.
그 말은 하나를 제외한 모든 Z 안정자 생성자를 곱하면 마지막 것이 나온다는 의미예요. 따라서 독립적이지 않아요. 하지만 어느 것 하나를 제거하면
독립적인 집합을 얻을 수 있어요. X 안정자 생성자들도 마찬가지예요. 각 유형에서 하나씩 제거할 수 있고,
어떤 것을 제거하는지는 상관없어요. 그러면 각 유형에서 L²-1개의 안정자 생성자가 남아요.
이를 명확히 하자면, 이건 이전 강의에서 언급했던 거예요. 실제로는 이 모든 안정자 생성자에 관심을 갖고, 엄밀히 운영적 의미에서
각 유형에서 하나를 무시하도록 선택하지는 않아요. 하지만 코드를 분석하기 위해서는
최소 생성 집합을 얻기 위해 각 유형의 안정자 생성자 하나가 제거된다고 상상할 수 있어요.
이를 유념하면서,
엄밀히 운영적 의미에서 각 유형에서 하나를 무시하도록 선택하지 않지만, 코드를 분석할 때는
최소 생성 집합을 얻기 위해 각 유형의 안정자 생성자 하나가 제거된다고 상상할 수 있어요.
이 제거된 생성자들의 결과를 같은 유형의 다른 모든 안정자 생성자 관측값의 결과로부터 추론할 수 있다는 걸 기억하세요.
그러므로 이 코드가 인코딩하는 qubit 수는 총 qubit 수,
즉 2×L²에서 최소 생성 집합의 총 안정자 생성자 수인 2×(L²-1)을 뺀 거예요.
그러면 2개의 qubit를 인코딩할 수 있다는 뜻이에요. 코드 공간이 비자명하다는 걸 따로 증명하지는 않았지만, 실제로 비자명하고,
안정자 생성자들을 곱해서 -1 곱하기 항등이 나올 수 없다는 걸 스스로 납득해 보세요.
그게 바로 토릭 코드 자체예요. 이 시점에서 이 코드가 왜 양자 오류 수정에 좋은지
전혀 명확하지 않을 수 있어요. 아직 분석이 남아있는데, 실제로
꽤 놀라운 양자 오류 수정 코드라는 걸 알게 될 거예요. 토릭 코드가 양자 오류 수정 코드로서 어떻게 작동하는지 이해하기 위해,
다양한 오류와 그것들이 생성하는 신드롬을 고려하는 것부터 시작할게요. 첫 번째로 주목할 점은
토릭 코드가 CSS 코드라는 거예요. 모든 안정자 생성자가 Z 또는 X 안정자
생성자이기 때문이에요. 그 의미는 X 오류와 Z 오류를 별도로 감지하고 수정할 수 있다는 거예요.
실제로 Z와 X 안정자 생성자 사이에는 간단한 대칭이 있어서 X 오류와 Z 오류를
본질적으로 같은 방식으로 분석할 수 있어요. 그래서 X 오류에 집중할 거예요. X 오류는 Z 안정자 생성자가 감지할 수 있고,
정확히 같은 아이디어를 사용해서 X 안정자 생성자가 감지할 수 있는 Z 오류로 변환할 수 있어요.
주기적 경계를 가진 L×L 격자의 모서리에 있는 2L² qubit들을 나타내는 그림이 여기 있어요.
이게 토러스 표면에 배치된다고 상상할 수 있어요. 지금은 모든 qubit가 파란색이에요.
오류에 영향받지 않은 qubit를 나타내는 거예요. 이 시점에서 qubit들의 상태가 이 코드의 코드 공간에 있다고 상상해야 해요.
언급했듯이 X 오류에 집중할 거고, 잠시 후 X 오류에 영향받은 qubit를 자홍색 원으로 표시할게요.
X 오류는 그림의 타일에 대응하는 Z 안정자 생성자에 의해 감지돼요.
그래서 흰색 타일은 +1 측정 결과, 즉 그 생성자에 대응하는 신드롬의 항목을 나타내고,
회색 타일은 -1 측정
결과를 나타낼 거예요. +1 결과, 즉 흰색 타일은 대응하는 안정자 생성자가 "행복"하다는 걸 나타낸다고 생각할 수 있어요.
이 생성자에 대해서는 모든 게 괜찮아 보여요. -1 결과나 회색 타일은
대응하는 안정자 생성자가 "불행"하다는 걸 나타내요. 명백히 이 결과를 초래한 오류가 발생했기 때문이에요.
지금은 오류가 발생하지 않았으므로 모든 안정자 생성자가 행복해요. Z 안정자 생성자는
타일에 접하는 4개의 qubit 패리티를 표준 기저에 대해 측정하는 것뿐이에요.
그러므로 +1 결과는 이 네 qubit에서 X 오류가 발생하지 않았다는 게 아니라, 짝수 개의 X 오류가 발생했다는 걸 나타내요.
-1 결과는 홀수 개의 X 오류가 발생했다는 걸 나타내요.
이제 X 오류를 하나 도입하고 무슨 일이 일어나는지 봐봐요.
이 qubit에 접하는 타일에 대응하는 두 Z 안정자 생성자가 이제 불행해요. 이 X 오류가 이 두 생성자 모두와 반교환하기 때문이에요.
또는 표준 기저로 표현하면, 두 타일에 대응하는 네 qubit 집합 모두 홀수 패리티 상태에 있어요.
그게 단일 X 오류의 효과예요. 신드롬을 측정하고 정확히 하나의 X 오류가 발생했다고 알거나 가정하면,
어떤 qubit가 뒤집혔는지 쉽게 추론할 수 있고 X gate로 다시 뒤집으면 돼요. 이제 추가 X 오류를 도입할 때 무슨 일이 일어나는지,
특히 두 번째 X 오류가 회색 타일 중 하나에 접하는 다른 qubit에서 발생하면 무슨 일이 생기는지 봐봐요.
예를 들어 위쪽 회색 타일처럼요. 그러면 그 타일에 접하는 qubit에서 두 X 오류가 발생해서 그 타일은 이제 행복해요.
2는 짝수이므로, 이 두 X 오류는 함께 이 타일의 안정자 생성자와 교환 가능해요.
다른 방식으로 표현하면, 이 두 번째 X 오류가 이 네 qubit의 모든 표준 기저 상태를 홀수 패리티에서 다시 짝수 패리티로 이동시켰어요.
반면 이 새 X 오류의 왼쪽 타일은 이제 불행해요.
새 X 오류를 계속 추가하는 이 과정을 계속할 수 있어요. 인접한 X 오류 체인을 형성하는 한,
인접하다는 건 qubit들이 같은 타일에 접한다는 의미인데, 효과적으로 이 -1 측정 결과를 밀어내는 거예요.
항상 인접한 오류 체인의 끝 점에서 -1 신드롬 측정 결과가 나온다는 걸 알 수 있어요.
따라서 끝 점이 있는 한 인접한 X 오류 체인은 항상 감지할 수 있어요. 여러 체인이 있을 수도 있는데, 이 가능성은 나중에 다시 다룰 거예요.
하지만 끝 점이 없는 인접한 X 오류 체인이 있을 수도 있어요. 오류 체인이 닫힌 루프를 형성할 수 있다는 거예요.
이렇게 닫힌 루프를 형성하도록 오류를 더 추가해봐요. 이제 모든 타일에 짝수 개의 X 오류가 생겼어요.
따라서 모든 안정자 생성자가 이제 행복해요. 인접한 X 오류의 닫힌 루프는 이 코드로 감지되지 않는다는 걸 알게 됐어요.
이런 경우 전부 +1인 신드롬을 얻기 때문이에요. 다소 실망스러워 보일 수 있어요. 실제로 닫힌 루프를 형성하려면 인접한 X 오류가 네 개만 있으면 돼요.
거리 4 코드보다 나은 걸 기대하는데, 하지만 일부 인접한 X 오류의 닫힌 루프는
그 자체로 안정자에 있어요. 격자의 각 꼭짓점에 X 안정자 생성자가 있다는 걸 기억하세요.
인접한 X 안정자 생성자들을 곱하면 X 연산의 닫힌 루프를 형성할 수 있어요.
방금 몇 분 전에 구성한 닫힌 루프처럼요. 그러니까 일부 인접한 X 오류의 닫힌 루프는
여기 표시된 것처럼 실제로 오류가 전혀 아니에요. 안정자에 있으므로 코드 공간에 아무런 영향을 미치지 않아요. 하지만
안정자에 없는 X 오류의 닫힌 루프도 있어요. 따라서 코드에 의해 감지되지 않는 비자명한 오류를 나타내요.
다양한 루프 유형을 특성화하는 꽤 단순한 방법이 있어요.
격자의 모든 선, 즉 위에서 아래로의 모든 수직선과 왼쪽에서 오른쪽으로의 모든 수평선을 짝수 번 교차하는 루프는
항상 X 안정자 생성자들의 곱이에요. 화면에 표시된 예시도 포함하고, 주기적 경계를 교차할 수 있는 훨씬 더 복잡한 루프도 포함해요.
하지만
안정자에 없는 X 오류의 닫힌 루프도 있고, 그것들은 코드에 의해 감지되지 않는 비자명한 오류를 나타내요.
다양한 루프 유형을 특성화하는 꽤 단순한 방법이 있어요.
격자의 모든 선을 짝수 번 교차하는 루프는 항상 X 안정자 생성자들의 곱이에요.
이는 화면에 표시된 예시와 주기적 경계를 교차할 수 있는 훨씬 복잡한 루프도 포함해요.
하지만
그럼에도 불구하고 이 닫힌 X 오류 루프에 X 안정자 생성자를 곱하면 효과적으로 아무것도 없는 상태로 줄어들 수 있어요.
그리고 X 안정자 생성자를 곱해야만 이런 루프를 얻을 수 있다는 건 분명해요. 모든 X 안정자
생성자는 모든 수평선과 모든 수직선에 짝수 개의 X 연산을 배치하기 때문이에요.
우리가 가질 수 있는 다른 유형의 닫힌 루프는 적어도 하나의 선을 홀수 번 교차하는 것이에요. 예를 들어
여기 표시된 것처럼 모든 수평선을 정확히 한 번 교차하는 루프가 있어요. 그리고 각 수직선을 정확히 한 번 교차하는 또 다른 예시도 있어요.
이들은 코드에 의해 감지되지 않는 비자명한 오류의 예시예요. 하지만 핵심은
이런 닫힌 루프를 형성하는 유일한 방법이 토러스 주위를 돌아가는 것이라는 거예요. 토러스의 구멍 주위를 돌거나 구멍을 통과하거나,
또는 둘 다일 수 있어요. 이건 토러스에 관한 위상적 속성이에요.
기본적으로 모두 구멍에 관한 거예요. 그래서 이걸 위상적 양자 오류 수정 코드라고 부르는 거예요.
주기적 경계를 가진 2차원 격자의 이 시각화로 표현하면, 이 범주의 체인은
X 안정자 생성자를 곱해서 루프를 한 점으로 수축시킬 수 없는 방식으로
하나 또는 두 개의 주기적 경계 주위를 돌아야 해요. 그런 체인은 여기 그림보다 더 복잡할 수 있지만,
이게 그런 루프가 가질 수 있는 가장 짧은 길이예요. 어떤 식으로든 하나 또는 두 개의 주기적 경계 주위를 돌아야 하기 때문이에요.
이것이 의미하는 건, 감지되지 않는 비자명한 오류의 최소 가중치가 L이라는 거예요.
그보다 오류가 적은 닫힌 루프는 반드시 첫 번째 범주에 속하므로 안정자에 있어요.
닫힌 루프를 형성하지 않는 오류 체인은 코드에 의해 감지돼요. 그게 전부예요. 이 코드가 작동하는 이유가 바로 이거예요.
결국 [[2L², 2, L]] 안정자 코드가 나와요. 2L² qubit를 사용해 2 qubit를 인코딩하고, 코드의 거리는 L이에요.
다음으로 토릭 코드로 오류를 수정하는 것에 대해 간략히 이야기할게요. 세부 사항은 너무 깊이 들어가지 않겠어요.
신드롬을 측정할 때, Z 안정자 생성자에 대해서만 말하자면, 전부 +1인 신드롬이 아닌 다른 걸 보면,
-1 결과는 하나 이상의 인접한 X 오류 체인의 끝 점을 알려줘요.
-1 결과들을 짝지어서 그 사이에 X 수정 체인을 형성해 이 오류들을 수정하려고 시도할 수 있어요.
그렇게 할 때, 수정을 위한 최단 경로를 선택하는 게 합리적이에요.
예를 들어, 여기 표시된 것과 같은 신드롬을 측정하면, 불행한 타일 사이의 이 경로를 선택하고 이 경로를 따라 X
gate를 수정으로 적용할 수 있어요. 물론 신드롬을 일으킨 실제 오류 체인은
여기 표시된 것처럼 다를 수 있지만, 오류와 수정이 함께 안정자에 속하는 한 괜찮아요.
수정이 토러스 주위를 완성하는 루프가 될 수도 있어요.
그건 나쁜 거예요. 논리적 오류를 발생시켰기 때문이에요. 따라서 최단 경로를 따라 수정하는 이 전략은
낮은 가중치 오류는 수정하지만 더 높은 가중치 오류에는 작동하지 않을 수 있어요. 물론 어떤 양자 오류 수정 코드에서도 그 이상을 기대할 수는 없어요.
노이즈 모델에 따라 더 그럴듯한 건, 신드롬에서 많은 -1을 관찰하는 경우예요. 이 경우 효율적인 고전 알고리즘을 사용해
짝을 짓고 신드롬을 나타내는 최소 가중치 오류를 찾을 수 있어요.
이전 강의에서 언급했듯이, 이게 신드롬에 대해 가장 그럴듯한 설명을 항상 수정하지는 않을 수 있지만,
일반적으로는 꽤 잘 작동해요. 가중치가 거리 L의 절반보다 엄격히 작은 오류는 항상 수정에 성공해요.
또한 다른 오류 모델에 더 적합한 다른 전략들도 있다는 걸 언급해야 해요. 토릭 코드가 발견된 지 25년이 넘었고, 그 시간 동안
양자 오류 수정 코드에 대한 많은 연구가 이루어졌어요.
토릭 코드에서 영감을 받은 다른 위상적 양자 오류 수정 코드들과 다른 아이디어를 기반으로 한 코드들도 있어요.
알려진 모든 다양한 코드 구성의 포괄적인 목록은 분명히 드릴 수 없지만,
표면만 조금 긁어봐서 잘 알려진 몇 가지 예시를 간략히 언급할게요.
먼저, 알고 보면 토릭 코드가 주기적 경계를 가지는 게 꼭 필수적인 건 아니에요.
토릭 코드의 일부를 잘라내서 토러스가 아닌 2차원 표면에 평평하게 배치할 수 있어요.
그렇게 해서 얻는 걸 surface 코드라고 해요.
예를 들어, 위아래에 소위 거친 가장자리, 옆면에 매끄러운 가장자리가 있는 패턴으로 격자의 가장자리를 자르고,
그에 따라 안정자 생성자의 경계 경우를 포함하면,
이번에는 하나의 qubit만 인코딩할 수 있는 코드가 나와요. 하지만 이 코드는 토릭 코드의 가장 중요한 특성을 여전히 상속해요.
특히, 이 코드의 감지되지 않는 비자명한 오류는 X 오류인지 Z 오류인지에 따라
왼쪽 가장자리에서 오른쪽 가장자리로 또는 위에서 아래로 뻗어 있는 오류 체인에 대응해야 해요.
대각선으로 가장자리를 잘라서 소위 회전된 surface 코드라고 불리는 것을 얻을 수도 있어요.
그렇게 하면 사용되는 qubit 수 측면에서 코드를 더 효율적으로 만드는 데 도움이 될 수 있어요.
예를 들어, 이 surface 코드를 취하고 일부 qubit를 버려서 대각선으로 방향이 잡힌 정사각형을 남기면
경계에서 안정자 생성자를 올바른 방식으로 지정하는 한, 또 다른 surface 코드를 얻어요.
이와 같은 다이어그램은 안정자 생성자가 어떻게 정의되는지 명확히 하는 데 도움이 돼요.
가장자리의 둥근 것을 포함한 검은 타일은 X 안정자 생성자를 나타내고,
흰 타일은 Z 안정자 생성자를 나타내요. 경계에 있는 것들은 이번에는 2 qubit XX 또는
ZZ 안정자 생성자예요. 그리고 이 다이어그램이 45° 회전된 걸 흔히 볼 수 있어요.
또 다른 흥미로운 코드 클래스로, 위상 코드의 일반 범주에도 속하는 것은 color
코드예요. 정확히 어떻게 작동하는지 설명하지는 않겠지만, 한 가지 생각 방식은 7 qubit Steane 코드의 기하학적 일반화라는 거예요.
7 qubit Steane 코드를 고려하고 화면에 표시된 것처럼
KCET 순서 규약을 사용해 qubit에 번호를 매긴다고 해봐요. 그러면 이 일곱 qubit를
여기 표시된 그래프의 꼭짓점과 연결할 수 있어요. 안정자 생성자가 그래프의 가장자리로 형성된 타일 또는 면과 일치한다는 걸 알 수 있어요.
각 타일에는 그 타일의 꼭짓점에 있는 qubit들에서만 비자명하게 작용하는 Z 안정자
생성자와 X 안정자 생성자가 항상 있어요.
그 타일의 꼭짓점에서 발견되는 qubit들에서요.
타일이요. 이건 좋아요. 토릭 코드처럼 이 코드에도 기하학적 국소성이 있어서, 안정자 생성자를 측정하기 위해
qubit를 먼 거리로 이동시킬 필요가 없거든요. Z와 X 안정자 생성자가 항상 정확히 같은 qubit 집합에서 비자명하게 작용한다는 것도 좋은데,
다음 강의에서 더 이야기할 내결함성 양자 계산과 관련된 이유들 때문이에요.
color 코드는 이 기본 패턴을 일반화하는 양자 오류 수정 코드예요. 다른 그래프를 사용해 본질적으로 같은 일을 해요.
예를 들어, 여기 작동하는 19개 꼭짓점의 그래프가 있어요.
이는 1 qubit를 19개로 인코딩하는 코드를 제공하고, 거리 5를 가져요.
이들을 color 코드라고 부르는 이유는, 그래프에 대한 필수 조건 중 하나가 면을 세 가지 색으로 칠할 수 있어야 한다는 거예요.
즉, 가장자리를 공유하는 두 면이 같은 색이 되지 않도록 세 가지 색으로 면을 칠할 수 있어야 해요.
색상 자체는 코드에 실제로 중요하지 않아요. 색상에 관계없이 각 면에 대한 X와 Z 안정자 생성자를 가져요. 하지만 색상은
어떻게 작동하는지 분석하는 데 중요한 것으로 나타나요. 그러니까 두 개의 매우 잘 알려진 코드 패밀리가 있는 거예요.
하지만 이 코드 패밀리들과 유사한 아이디어를 기반으로 한 것들을 포함해서 완전히 다른 것들까지, 알려진 많은 다른 구성들이 있어요.
IBM의 제 동료 일부가 최근 발견한 양자 오류 수정 코드의 구체적인 예시는
gross 코드라고 알려져 있어요. 이름의 유래는 gross가 dozen의 dozen, 즉 144이기 때문이에요.
특히 이 코드는 12 qubit를 144 qubit로 인코딩하고, 거리는 12예요.
이 코드가 어떻게 작동하는지 자세히 설명하지는 않겠어요. 토릭 코드와 유사하지만, 각 안정자 생성자가 조금 더 떨어진 두 개의 추가 qubit를 포함해요.
surface 코드처럼 평면 임베딩이 없지만, 소위 biplanar 임베딩을 가져요. 하나가 아닌 두 개의 qubit 레이어가 필요해요.
bivariate bicycle 코드라는 코드 패밀리에 속하고, 이들에 대해 특히 주목할 만한 건
토릭 코드나 surface 코드보다 훨씬 효율적이라는 거예요. 동시에 대략 같은 오류율을 허용하면서 훨씬 더 많은 qubit를 인코딩할 수 있어요.
gross 코드의 경우, 신드롬 측정을 위해 추가로 144 qubit가 필요해요.
그래서 필요한 총 qubit 수는 288이 되는데, 이는 오늘날의 기술을 위한 매우 유망한 후보가 돼요.
이것으로 이번 강의를 마칠게요. CSS 코드, 토릭 코드, 그리고 surface 코드와 color 코드를 포함한
다른 양자 코드 구성들을 살짝 엿본 양자 오류 수정 코드 구성들에 관한 강의였어요.
내결함성 양자 계산에 관한 시리즈의 마지막 강의에서 함께하시길 바랍니다.
오류에 취약한 연산과 컴퓨팅 구성 요소를 사용해
인코딩된 양자 상태에서 계산을 수행하는 도전을 다루는 강의예요.
그때까지 안녕히 계세요.